[Music]
it must melt in your mouth
this great big story is inspired by
genesis
[Music]
this is chef and food historian hatching
lillian she's popular for her famous
saint nicholas cookies recipe that was
passed down by her ancestors
[Music]
the san nicolas cookies were brought to
the philippines by the spanish in the
1600s to solve an egg yolk dilemma the
country faced
buildings and churches
has
[Music]
which was how to make use of the excess
egg yolks
spanish nuns began to teach local women
recipes to solve their issues
[Music]
the cookies were named after an italian
saint saint nicholas of tolentino and
are said to possess the saints healing
powers
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
while the cookies remain popular today
for hatching lillian these cookies also
represent her past
your
[Music]
grandmother that is more than almost 300
years later
because of their rich history it's
important for acting lillian to pass
down her baking skills and preserve the
tradition of making these cookies
you must be very accurate in your
measurement
and nicolas is more by feel
again
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
you